hi and welcome to another gadget lab
show I'm Michael colori and I'm
Alexandra Chang today we have a release
preview of windows 8 and i also have a
new Chromebook and we're gonna take a
little bit of wireless speaker and we're
also going to give away a mouse a very
special wireless mouse touchy touchy
swipey swipey yeah speaking of swiping
swiper show us Windows 8 so this is the
final I guess preview build of windows 8
we saw the consumer preview and this is
the release preview it was just released
on Thursday and it has a few new things
three new apps the news app and a sports
app and a travel up so these are all
just like native apps that will come
built-in on windows 8 and those show up
in the Metro interface right and this is
so this is the Metro interface and
Windows 8 has two interfaces the Metro
UI which is what starts like it's the
start screen I guess and what people
will see when they launch Windows 8 then
you can also go into a desktop mode
which is more familiar for people who
have windows 7 or previous versions of
Windows very cool yes so now this is
this is the the Metro UI is the one
that's been sort of optimized for touch
screens right right it's it's optimized
for touch screen so you can if this were
a touchscreen you could just tap on apps
and that would open the app but what
Microsoft gave us was a non-touchscreen
device and they sort of wanted us I
guess to play with the touchpad gestures
and they have it's still in prototype or
beta so they work pretty well though ya
know it works pretty well so you can
swipe in from like one corner to sort of
switch between apps so that's swiping in
from the left and then when you're in an
app you can swipe in from the right and
you go at the charms menu which can
bring you back to the start screen
each arms yeah it's pretty good i mean
the scrolling is what still needs work
but i'm assuming in the final build of
windows 8 which is supposed to come out
in october everything will be fixed yeah
so if you're buying a new laptop in in
like october november around the
holidays this is what you're gonna see
right now the the news that shows up in
the news app is that tied like any
particular service or can you customize
that so that is going to be aggregated
through I guess Bing which so there's
like a third a few ways that it creates
the news you get it through trends and
then that way it pulls from bing search
facebook and twitter and it basically
gets all of the most popular news and
pulls that up and you can also just go
through they have I think like maybe 40
to 50 different sources that they also
pull a lot of news from major major
sources local sources it might even be
more than 50 but you can also do like
little specific searches so let's say
you're interested in food trucks in
particular you can search food trucks
and get have a little tile and with all
the food truck news coming in so you'll
never never be out of the loop that
never being uninformed right well that's
very cool um I brought a laptop cool
yeah you want to see it yes it's a brand
new Chromebook so this is pretty much
the antithesis I don't know what the
right word is but the the opposite of
that this is a samsung laptop running
Chrome OS which is the operating system
that google puts out that is entirely
web-based so it does have a desktop but
it's very rudimentary desktop and when
you open it up all you get is a browser
so it runs the google chrome the google
chrome browser it's the same browser
experience that you would have on on the
mac or on a windows pc except that's all
there is here there's a very basic file
system underneath it so you can store
files you can dry drop things tune from
the SD card through the SD card slot or
through USB stick there's a couple USB
ports on here it's basically a laptop
that is for people who only need things
that are available through the browser
so if you're a gmail user if you keep
all of your documents in Google Drive
and access them through google docs this
is a machine that's going to give you
everything you need and it does require
an internet connection so what happens
when you don't have an internet
connection and you want to say like
create a google doc you're screwed good
well actually you need you you need to
get the version of this that comes with
verizon wireless broadband so this sales
is to separate computers there's one
that's four hundred and fifty dollars
which is just the Wi-Fi version of the
laptop and then there's another one
which is five hundred and fifty dollars
which comes with 100 megabytes of free
broadband from verizon a month for two
years two years its shape though yeah
you know it's relatively inexpensive is
a hundred dollars for two years of
connectivity if you need more you can
buy a day pass but it's not really meant
for people to be sitting there streaming
youtube videos and netflix and stuff
like that it's so that you can that she
said get your dogs right quickly so it's
there I mean is there any offline mode
like if you want to write Docs and you
don't have internet connection there
isn't right now but google has its
developer conference coming up at the
end of june and the google people that
we spoke to last week told us that
offline syncing for google docs will be
available sometime around the i/o
conference at the end of june so
sometime during the month of june you
will gain the ability to sync your docs
to your Chromebook so that when you're
on the road you have access to them and
you can also open up a new doc and start
typing without any worries they gave us
a machine and for testing that
particular feature and I tested it and
it was it worked like a charm well
that's exciting as I professa that was a
drawback with Chromebooks yeah and for
me that was the thing that was missing I
mean I have the old Chromebook as well
which we tested last year this one is
much improved it has a way better
trackpad it has keyboard is very similar
to the series 9 hardware that we were
just demoing windows 8 on it has a nice
screen the screen can be a little bit
better but hardware itself is fine but
yeah that was the thing was really
missing it was missing that that that
piece of offline productivity that is
crucial it's half the reason you buy a
laptop so you can do work when you're
not in your house right so when that
arrives it'll be an over-the-air update
and it'll make this a much better device
shuttle cements and it's it's it's
handsome it's about three pounds yeah
it's it's very portable looks like it
doesn't come with this big gmail stick
anything I put that on there sparkly
yeah I like its kind of psychedelic
shall we move on yeah what else do you
have the other gadget we have to show is
this it's a speaker it looks like a tiny
black box it does it's like it's a high
black box it's from new force that's nu
force one word it's an audio a mobile
audio company and a home audio company
they're well known for making DEA seized
digital to analog converter boxes
basically things that you use to make
your digital music sound better when
you're listening to it on pair of
speakers or a pair of headphones when
you're sitting down do they look like
this yeah this is pretty typical of
their design I mean everything is kind
of austere and you know simple colors
this comes in like black red white blue
but I particularly like the black one
the speaker is right here it's a grill
like sort of a the cloth girl in front
of it so it's hidden on now it's not a
wireless speaker you charge it up and
it's a battery inside but then you use
it you plug your smartphone into it or
you can plug it into your computer and
when you plug your phone into it just
through the headphone jack it's just a
speaker okay when you plug your computer
into it using the USB cable it actually
turns into a DAC box so it takes the
digital audio from your computer not
through the head
Jack but through the USB port which is a
higher quality connection and you get
better sounding audio through the
speaker so how much better is it then
let's say a laptop well through this
speaker marginally better okay but when
it's connected via USB and you're using
the the DAC feature of it you can plug
your headphones into it and it turns it
into a portable headphone amp so the
sound that you get when you have this
sitting between like when you when you
plug this in your computer via USB and
then you plug your headphones into it
the sound you get through your
headphones is way better okay then what
you get through your laptop and I say
way better meaning you know it's
marginally better but audio files will
notice the difference and they'll be
quite pleased and how much does it cost
120 bucks not bad so you know it's it's
pretty cool as a speaker like I took it
to the park and plug my phone into it
listen to it and it's you know sounds
about as good as Jambox it's not smaller
yeah it's not wireless it's not as loud
as a jam box but the sound quality is
about they're so pretty solid little
product haven't got the chance to fully
test it you know with the different
kinds of headphones and things like that
but I can say that it does compare very
well two new forces other headphone amps
call so a new force does a lot of
headphone amps like between 100 and 300
dollars and this has if not the same
circuitry very similar circuitry at
least from what my ears can tell very
nice yeah we love our very sleek we love
our little tiny speakers on the gadget
lab this is something they will have a
full review of this up on we're calm in
the in the near future and there's a
full review of the Chromebook up on
wired com right now you can read and are
you doing a first look on Windows 8 or
you get a new story about it um yeah
that went up on Thursday also so
hands-on with the whole release preview
sweet so you want to get the details and
then there's the mouse yes the fancy
fancy
mouse so this mouse is really special
I've actually been using the older
version of this and I love it it's
pretty cool so this is from Microsoft
hardware and basically what they're just
a division of Microsoft that makes mice
and keyboards pretty much and this is
their latest creation the Arc Touch
Mouse it's been it's been around for a
while but this is what makes this one
really special is that it is a limited
edition 30 year anniversary mouse which
means that there are only 30 of these
made they're not selling them and they
gave us one that we decided to give away
to our lucky or one lucky viewer has
hand painted like a hand painted 30
right there and 30 years of hardware how
do you know what he needed I was told by
a Microsoft spokesperson so what do they
have they have like a person with
extremely dainty hands yes Seattle like
doing perfect circles probably huh just
like painting it but they basically the
problem is with this they warned me and
told me not to use it on a daily basis
because they don't know how well the
paint will survive so I think it's more
of like a cabinet thing like a
collector's item sure ah if you want to
win a mouse you can't use this is it um
so you know this this is it's actually
pretty sweet yeah a feature with like
you showed how it clicks it arches like
that look cats back and that's how you
turn it on and then when you want to dis
activated or deactivated or disabled it
you just flatten it out yeah and you
just put this little USB plug into your
computer and it connects wirelessly and
then when you're not using it stick it
back on and it's magnetic yeah so you
don't lose it it's pretty cool um I was
actually kind of bummed when I got mine
i ordered it just blindly I was like
wireless mouse and click and it came in
the mail and it I was bummed it wasn't
you know like a bluetooth mouse like
mice I was expecting but it's actually
kind of nice because the battery lasts a
lot longer yeah it lasts way long
actually suppose um so if you want to
win it here's our trivia question and
you just have to answer this trivia
question by hitting us up on Twitter at
gadget lab and it is how many pounds in
a stone that's it cheating as always is
encouraged that's all we have yeah thank
you we'll see you next week